à
comme péter wright hot fuzz
bonjour à tous je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui une partie qui m'a ont pesé
à jean-noël riffs qui a été disputée
l'année dernière en championnat suisse
par équipes
cette partie il s'agit d'une défense
scandinave
malgré lors d'autres coups un peu
atypique après l'es4 j'ai joué cavalier
cécile ce parce que je voulais discuter
d'une variante bien précise que j'aurais
pas obtenu en jouant des cinq au premier
coup le deuxième cavaliere après le
deuxième coup je me lève 3 des 5
premiers singles i'm prenez cinq cas
malice et 3 tab à 5
jean noël a joué des deux des cadres qui
est le coup le plus tentant mais
peut-être que 5 fu des 5 fu 17 et
seulement maintenant des quatre est une
façon plus gênantes pour les noirs que
le sud plus gênant pour le nord que la
suite de la partie façon plus gênante de
tester le système loire après cinq des
cadres se joue il faut juger quatre avec
l'idée de d'effectuer le grand roque
rapidement et d'exercer une pression sur
le pion des quatre ce qui s'est passé
après groupe b 5 prend 1,7 faux
processes des processus alors comme
bilan de l'ouverture on voit que les
noirs ont gagné la perte de fous qu'ils
exercent une pression sur le chef des
quatre mecs leur maroc est affaibli ici
jean noël a joué le coup h2 h3 qui assez
logique
une partie plus récente puisque disputé
cet été par sébastien feller le côté
noir toujours s'était poursuivie par md
3 1 8e coup et maintenant sébastien à
jouer c'est cette c5
pour accentuer la pression sur le plan
des caps après des cinq que six coups
des deux c4 thème prends ces quatre faux
prince 3g prend un soin l'osdh un peu
prend des 5
d'objets quatre échecs
enfin dès 8 ans rock ko-96 les noirs
n'ont pas eu de problème d'ouverture et
sébastien a fini par battre son
adversaire le et me sacha kaeppelin
revenons à 8 h 3 le coup choisi par jean
noël ici les changes faut prendre 3 sera
défavorable au noir après d'un point 9 3
pour prendre quatre
il suivrait d'un premier set ou deux en
france et 6 sur le retrait du fourrage 5
je suivrai 9 g 2 et 4 fuji six cavaliers
5 et les noirs ont également des soucis
malheureusement il ya une troisième
possibilité mais coup d'un match 5
et maintenant après 9,2 me deux faux
preuve 3g prend un f3 précis ce qui est
la suite de la partie les noirs ont une
position correcte probablement proche de
l'égalité les deux camps ont des plans
doubler les blancs f2 f3 les noirs on
sait cette c5
mais alors que ceux des blancs pour
rester doublé un moment et noir peuvent
nourrir l'espoir de jouer c'est cette c5
et se débarrasser d'une pion de tête
ici jean noël a choisi aux cavaliers 4
qui est plus ambitieux que le coup full
3d sont de l'ordre de 4 il voulait en
effet joué c2 c3 pour défendre le pion
des quatre par une autre pion et trouver
un avenir plus radieux sont fous ces 1
soit angers 5 soit en f4 d'où ma
réaction de principe
onze tours prend des cadres qui prend
l'appuyons central des blancs il fallait
quand même estimé les
complications qui surviennent il voir
que la position à la droite de la tour
magne être que temporaire ici j'en ai
joué douze poules 3 kit il coupe les
attendait sachant que sur 12 damas six
échecs
j'aurais joué au 17
le pion h3 et en mer et sur dame prend à
les noirs dispose d'une jolie tourné un
échec sacrifiant nato seront à prendre
dans trois 3 pas d2 l'an prochain et
n'auront en plus en plus les deux rois
seront mal placé m donc les noirs
doivent être un petit peu lieu
après 12 ou trois je jouais damas cinq
échecs c3 et maintenant le coût un peu
d'équilibrisme tour à 4 ce coup n'était
pas tant destinée à attaquer le puits 1
2 que transférer la tour sur la 5eme
angers comme ce sera le cas dans la
suite de la partie ici les blancs ont
joué le naturel 14 petit rock b3 et je
souhaite activement à cause de tour
points 4 f points 4 d'un procès d'un
procès trop un check point f1 d'un point
moi j'ai deux dames 5 lames à 6 échecs
par 17 temps d 1
et maintenant après faut des six les
noirs repousse la tacc reste avec une
pièce de plus après 14 petit rock
j'ai joué dans les cinq dames ces deux
cas vis à vis ici les blancs on voit pu
récupérer le pion qu'ils avaient
sacrifié on joue en kabylie g5 suivi de
cavalli programme cet après 16v trois
tours à 5
bekkat dans ma carte là c'est ici que
survient la finale si les blancs jouent
18 d'un point à 4 tours prend 1,4 et
cavalli g5 à ce moment là après fou des
six cavaliers pros 27 et nous rejouer
très vite disposerait d'une case forte
en d5 pour leurs cavaliers et la
position sera équilibré
à la place le meilleur cours et est ici
18 dames b3 avec une position
sensiblement égales le coup de jean-noël
18 m2 est inférieure et des blancs on va
avoir quelques difficultés tour h5
voilà le transfert de la tour est
effectué maintenant j'envisage de jouer
d'un bep 5 suivi de dames f5 avec une
forte attaque contre l'europe blanc ce
qui est motivé sans doute jaune
bonjour les thermalies g3 ton âge trois
ans g2 mais maintenant après tour h
quatre rouges et 5
la tour qui semble être perdu s'échappe
grâce à l'astuce maintien cavaliers des
la tour est imprenable à cause de la
fourchette qu'il y avait quatre échecs
et la partie se termine joliment tôt à
d1 menaçante au point dès 5h 6 alors à
la place de de 22 h 6 j'aurais pu jouer
cavalier princes et rois et la tour des
huit échecs premier set down i iii était
gênant après h6 je me la réponse du tour
prenez 5 mène à son tour à 5 es fou
contre 4 et maintenant lapointe de
finale 23 tours age 2 échecs ce roi
proche d'eux lé nord jouer h projet cinq
échecs ou intermédiaire puis s'est
promenée 5 et restaurants et de pions le
plus tandis qu'après roi g1 s'éprend des
5 fu f4 ou poule 3 la tour repartirait
en h4
après tout rage 2 échecs donc les noirs
ont gardé de plus en plus et avoir un
avantage décisif
raison pour laquelle les blancs -
monique